why i simplified my website so i got an
email from an author not too long ago on
my website we've got about 8 000 people
who contribute to my website and he
wrote in to say
why is it that you don't have social
media sharing links on your website so
somebody goes to his article you can't
click on the simple
tweet button facebook like button any of
that stuff he said why did he do that
like people should want to share this
stuff
and i got into this whole thing on email
with him and he came out loving it but
here's the reason why okay if you look
at my website it's changed a lot over
the past couple years
the philosophy here is we want to
minimize the amount of work and the
amount of options that we give people
because when you minimize the options
and you make it powerful you're more
likely to get somebody to follow through
if you have somebody come to your
website and it's full of stuff so many
options what are they going to do
they're going to be confused they won't
know what to do and they're going to
bounce
ideally what i want to do is for people
who are writing content for my website i
want to have it so that the article is
so good
that people will go to twitter on their
own and share it
right that's the test i'm sure you've
been on some websites where
you love the content so much that you
wanted to share it even though there was
that little button on there so we're
trying to minimize distractions some of
the other things that we did was uh we
eliminated the sidebar so there's no
sidebar on anywhere on the website it's
just a flowing down piece of content
because again we're distracting from the
reader if you're reading something
that's great and then they have to jump
to the sidebar then you're distracting
their flow and it's not a great thing
for them to do
i also have a bit of a beef with top
navigation and this is uh maybe a
personal rant of mine and
i don't know we'll see if i stick with
it but but i'm feeling like
right now you look at my website at the
top there's no navigation it's just a
video
and my reason for doing this was i'm
looking at my sign looking at me doing a
redesign i thought you know everybody
has the top nav so what do i put in my
top net
and i was sitting with my designers you
know i'm just going to kill the top nav
i don't want a top nav
the reason is why do you have a top nav
okay
if you have content and somebody's
coming to your website okay they're
reading your homepage they start
scrolling down
if they're not reading anything and
they're distracted by your top nav right
if they're clicking away before they
even scroll down on your page then the
content sucks right the content on your
homepage sucks they're not reading it
they're bouncing right away going to
somewhere else on your site
so fix your content make it better
the other option is
if they do like the content you know
they are scrolling down reading
whatever's on your homepage or whatever
page they land on you're then making
them scroll all the way back to the top
to navigate your site that's me that
didn't make sense
it made sense that you should have great
content that people should want to read
and should want to scroll you're
minimizing the options for them to get
distracted on and then at the bottom you
have your bottom navigation you have
your footer navigation where they can go
for next steps to learn more to me that
just makes a lot of sense of how
somebody should
work through a website uh maybe on them
i mean i know i'm in a huge minority uh
and a big problem is most websites are
too cluttered they're too full of crap
too many distractions
and the content sucks you know the
content is bad so i'm clicking away
we're make good content make me want to
read it make me want to get engaged with
it and then right there at the bottom i
don't want people clicking away right at
the top right there at the bottom as a
next step when i'm reading your your
website say
that's really cool what these guys do i
want to learn more oh boom right here
here's my next step make it easy for
people remove the distractions so the
author who wrote in i wrote this whole
long email to his really short question
and he wrote in to say uh i wish i i
wish i saved that tweet i'm feeling sick
if you can't tell right now
so my mind is a little
uh
anyway
he wrote back to say you know what that
was exactly the answer that i hoped you
would say
and he he followed me on twitter and he
wrote you know because you stand for
something you've gained a new follower
and so that's what you want to do with
your business try it simplify it make
your content more valuable remove
distractions and watch your business
grow believe those are watching like the
video thumbs up below
leave a comment ask a question i'll make
a video response and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much and i'll see you soon